[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo
de áfrica 7 días este es un magazine
100% dedicado al continente africano mi
nombre es andrés meza muños y estos son
nuestros titulares golpe de estado en su
daño el ejército apoyado por algunos
opositores disolvió al gobierno de
transición arrestó al primer ministro y
tomó el poder miles de personas salieron
a las calles para protestar contra el
golpe que fue condenado por la comunidad
internacional
se reanuda en burkina faso el juicio por
el asesinato del ex presidente thomas
sankara el llamado che guevara africano
murió hace 34 años durante un golpe de
estado 14 hombres son enjuiciados entre
los que destaca el ex amigo y sucesor de
sankara bless compadre en la región este
de la república democrática del congo
asolada por la guerra ahora se combate
por la paz pero en un torneo de karate
el evento acogió a 5 países de la región
de los grandes lagos que ha estado
plagada de violencia
empezamos en sudán donde el ejército
tomó el poder y puso bajo arresto
domiciliario a varios miembros del
gobierno de transición el golpe de
estado se produce dos años después de
que los manifestantes forzaron la salida
de omar al bashir y sólo unas semanas
antes de que se suponía que se
entregaría el liderazgo del país a los
civiles el hecho provocó el descontento
de la ciudadanía que salió a las calles
en medio de la represión de las
autoridades y ya dejan varios muertos la
comunidad internacional condenó la
situación y pidió el respeto a la
democracia echamos un vistazo a la
historia del que en su día fue el país
más grande de áfrica
tiempo atrás fue el país más grande de
áfrica sudán tiene una población de 43
millones de personas en su mayoría
musulmanas con el árabe como lengua
oficial y fronteras que se extienden
hasta el mar rojo un país desgarrado por
las guerras civiles primero entre las
regiones del norte y del sur dos guerras
de 17 y 22 años y millones de muertos en
2005 se firmó un acuerdo de paz seis
años después sudán del sur proclama su
independencia en el occidente otra
guerra sacude a sudan en 2003 en la
región de darfur un conflicto entre las
fuerzas sudanesas y los rebeldes de las
minorías étnicas que acabó con la vida
de 300.000 personas y desplazó
internamente a 2,5 millones durante 30
años sudan fue gobernado con puño y
hierro por omar al bashir hasta ser
destituido por el ejército en 2019
después de cuatro meses de masivas
protestas populares el ex dictador es
acusado de genocidio y crímenes de lesa
humanidad debido a las violaciones de
derechos humanos y supuestos vínculos
con el terrorismo sudan está bajo el
embargo de eeuu nunca ha podido
desarrollar y es uno de los países más
empobrecidos del mundo la escasez de gas
electricidad y combustible es algo
cotidiano para los sudaneses la secesión
del sur en 2011 también privó de casi
todas las reservas de petróleo en el
ámbito cultural la nación africana
cuenta con muchos tesoros arqueológicos
inexplorados pirámides en particular más
numerosas que en egipto riquezas aún
desconocidas
mientras tanto en mali las autoridades
interinas anunciaron que solo hasta
diciembre se conocerá cuando se
celebrarán las elecciones que
devolverían el poder a la sociedad civil
para entonces deberá celebrarse primero
una conferencia nacional de grupos
civiles y políticos para acordar una
fecha el anuncio llega tras la visita de
una delegación del consejo de seguridad
de la onu que visitó el país para
evaluar el proceso de transición a la
democracia tras los dos golpes de estado
en menos de un año
y en burkina faso el histórico juicio
por el asesinato del ex presidente
thomas sankara se reanudó este 25 de
octubre después de haber sido suspendido
durante dos semanas los abogados de los
acusados habían solicitado este tiempo
para analizar unas 20.000 páginas del
proceso 14 acusados son juzgados por un
tribunal militar en la capital burkinesa
uagadugú el juicio estuvo cerca de nunca
llevarse a cabo ya que el gobierno de
bless compaoré ex presidente de burkina
faso y principal inculpado en el caso
bloqueó por 27 años los procedimientos
judiciales no fue hasta su caída en 2014
que se allanó el camino para que el
juicio se pudiera llevar a cabo en el
siguiente informe detallamos quién fue
thomas sankara apodado 'el che guevara
africano
thomas sankara nació en 1949 en el norte
rural de lo que entonces se conocía como
alto volta una colonia francesa sin
salida al mar después de recibir
formación militar en el extranjero
sankara llegó al poder en 1983 en un
golpe militar dirigido por su amigo
íntimo place compadre yo a un estilo de
vida simple huyendo de lujo mudándose
con su familia un humilde palacio
presidencial y reduciendo su propio
salario bajo su mandato alto volta pasó
a llamarse burkina faso que significa la
tierra de los hombres íntegros durante
sus cuatro años como presidentes ankara
supervisó una serie de reformas que
hicieron que la tasa de alfabetización
se disparara del 13% al 73% se apoderó
de las tierras de los grandes
terratenientes y las entregó
directamente a los agricultores pobres
impulsando la producción de trigo
sankara fue un firme defensor de los
derechos de la mujer prohibiendo la
mutilación genital y los matrimonios
forzados pero quizás fueron sus acciones
en la escena mundial las que le valieron
el apodo del che guevara de áfrica en la
onu sankara se pronunció contra lo que
denominaba guerras imperialistas y el
apartheid pidió a las naciones africanas
que se negarán a pagar su deuda a los
países occidentales y desafió a francia
que había conservado una enorme
influencia en muchas de sus antiguas
colonias
sus críticas lo convirtieron en el líder
del movimiento panafricano
transformándolo en una figura mítica más
de tres décadas después de su muerte
pero sus críticos dicen que tenía un
lado más oscuro que utilizo para
mantener su dominio del poder en 1985
amnistía internacional informó de que
sus opositores eran detenidos sin juicio
y torturados tras sólo cuatro años en el
poder sankara fue abatido por soldados
durante un golpe de estado que dejó a su
amigo blaze compadre solo en el poder
pasamos a libia este 20 de octubre se
cumplieron 10 años de la muerte del
gobernante libio moamar al gadafi que
tras un levantamiento nacional alentado
por la primavera árabe fue derrocado y
asesinado meses después una década más
tarde la situación hoy en día en el país
africano no ha mejorado los habitantes
aún lidian con la inestabilidad
económica la proliferación de armas y
una nación dividida entre las facciones
del este y el oeste que están en guerra
desde 2014 informe de andré amaya
muamar al gadafi el excéntrico autócrata
que gobernó libia durante 42 años murió
hace una década en 1969 él lideró el
golpe de estado militar que derrocó al
rey idrís al-senussi instauró un consejo
de la revolución con el que hizo grandes
cambios en el país entre la década de
1990 y los años 2000 con el abandono del
desarrollo de armas de destrucción
masiva libia salió de la categoría
estado paria a la de miembro pleno de la
comunidad internacional hábil
revolucionario idealista pero también
imprevisible temido y déspota al gadafi
reprimió duramente algunas
manifestaciones de sus opositores en
febrero de 2011 la violenta represión
contra la disidencia provocó una guerra
civil en cuestión de meses los
opositores lograron dominar gran parte
del territorio libio con la toma de
trípoli en agosto de 2011 al gadafi cuyó
a la ciudad de sirte desde donde gobernó
paralelamente al instalado consejo
nacional de transición con el
advenimiento de la primavera árabe que
derrocó a los gobernantes de túnez y
egipto a principios de 2011 se inició
una revuelta popular en libia contra el
gadafi cercado por sus oponentes trató
de huir por una alcantarilla pero lo
atraparon y mataron de inmediato para
muchos su muerte significó el fin de la
tiranía y la dictadura sin embargo el
poder estatal se vino abajo y se
formaron dos gobiernos en enero de este
año se acordó que abdul hamid baby sería
el primer ministro interino quien debe
preparar las elecciones presidenciales y
parlamentarias de diciembre que por lo
pronto se han pospuesto un mes diez años
después de la desaparición de al gadafi
los libios siguen lidiando con la
inestabilidad la proliferación de armas
una economía que se hunde y una tasa de
desempleo del 19 por ciento y en nigeria
cientos de personas salieron a las
calles de la ciudad de lagos el pasado
20 de octubre para rechazar la
brutalidad policial justo cuando se
cumple un año de las movilizaciones que
sacudieron al país y que rechazaban el
ya disuelto escuadrón especial antirrobo
señalado de cometer abusos
agentes de la policía lanzaron gases
lacrimógenos para intentar dispersar las
protestas los manifestantes reclamaron
que las autoridades no han aprendido la
lección y pidieron justicia para quienes
fueron arrestados o murieron en manos de
las fuerzas de seguridad del año pasado
cientos de personas aún se encuentran en
prisión o bajo custodia policial a la
espera de un juicio por cargos que van
desde incendios provocados hasta
asesinatos
y benín se sumó a la pequeña lista de
países africanos que permiten el aborto
en la mayoría de los casos tras un
acalorado debate el parlamento aprobó la
interrupción del embarazo que sólo era
legal en casos de violación incesto si
la vida de la madre corría peligro o por
temas de salud del feto ahora la nueva
ley estipula que el aborto es legal si
el embarazo puede agravar o causar una
situación de angustia material educativa
profesional o moral incompatible con los
intereses de la mujer y el feto la nueva
normativa representa un alivio para las
mujeres que enfrentan embarazos no
deseados en un país donde los abortos
inseguros son responsables del 20 por
ciento de las muertes maternales a nivel
nacional
y con el objetivo de promover la paz y
la convivencia pacífica entre los países
vecinos de la región de los grandes
lagos sacudida por múltiples crisis de
seguridad la república democrática del
congo acogió la primera edición del
llamado torneo de karate para la amistad
esta competición tuvo lugar en goma la
capital de la norteña región de kivú una
zona devastada por el conflicto armado
en la región este de la república
democrática del congo asolada por la
guerra ahora se combate por la paz pero
en un torneo de karate desde tanzania
burundi y uganda decenas de jóvenes
llegaron a goma para recoger medallas
pero eso no fue lo más importante
estamos aquí para ganar medallas y
también para buscar la paz en la región
de los grandes lagos esta primera
edición del torneo de la amistad entre
los países de los grandes lagos se
centra en el tema de la paz jóvenes
deportistas de toda la región pudieron
así encontrar un espacio para transmitir
sus mensajes
el karate es un deporte que se practica
de forma pacífica por eso cuando alguien
pierde si queda tranquilo y todo va bien
lo que hacemos aquí no es una guerra
porque no nos enojamos al final
sonreímos juntos compartimos y todo esto
demuestra que nos mueve un espíritu de
amor y paz una iniciativa que algunos
quisieran ver y mulata
nos gustaría que otros países como
uganda burundi o tanzania también
organizarán este tipo de torneos en el
futuro porque aquí sentimos el deseo de
convivir en el amor la fraternidad y no
en la guerra este torneo nos une como
una familia
durante casi tres décadas la región de
los grandes lagos se ha visto sacudida
por múltiples crisis de seguridad cada
país sospechando que sus vecinos quieren
de estabilizarlo la situación
humanitaria en la zona es ahora una de
las más grandes del mundo con millones
de muertos y de desplazados desde el
inicio del conflicto
que finalizamos con imágenes de la
ceremonia de premiación del festival
panafricano de cine y televisión de
uagadugú uno de los mayores festivales
de cine del continente africano que se
celebra cada dos años desde 1969 y que
estaba programado para realizarse a
finales de febrero pero tuvo que ser
pospuesto debido a la pandemia de kobe
19 en esta edición la cinta la esposa
del sepulturero del director somalí
ahmed haidar se llevó el semental dorado
de jane en premio a 'mejor película'
superando a otros 16 filmes de otros
directores africanos de esta manera
despedimos esta emisión de áfrica siete
días recuerden que si quieres repetir
este u otro capítulo pueden visitar
nuestra página web www punto frente 4
punto com
[Música]